[Musique]
faeno le petit dodo pria a Linda Nelson
Orphie
édition il y a bien longtemps sur une
petite île tropicale appelée île Maurice
vivait phenno un petit dodo phenno
voulait faire une surprise à sa maman à
l'occasion de son anniversaire il se
leva donc de bon matin décidé à dénicher
un cadeau tout spécial pour
elle PHENO alla chercher son meilleur
ami le singe Chiki et ensemble ils
s'enfoncèrent dans la forêt en quête du
cadeau
mais quelle belle fleur s'exclame ma
phéau voilà ce que je vais offrir à
maman il cueillit alors bien
délicatement la plus grosse et la plus
éclatante fleur d'hibiscus du Buisson
c'est tout simplement parfait dit-il et
ils prirent joyeusement le chemin du
retour oh non s'écria soudainement feno
alors qu'ils étaient presque arrivés à
la maison regarde la jolie fleur de
maman est toute fanée et elle n'est
vraiment plus belle du tout c'est
sûrement à cause de la chaleur dit Chiki
ne t'inquiète pas feno je vais t'aider à
trouver un autre cadeau allons voir
tabita la tortue elle saura certainement
où trouver quelque chose de beau pour ta
maman pourquoi ne lui offrirais-tu pas
une de ces belles grosses noix de coco
de l'autre côté de la rivière lui
proposa tabita la tortue qu'il
trouvèrent en en train de se reposer
sous un palmier c'est une excellente
idée répondit PHENO et les deux amis se
mirent aussitôt en quête d'un cocotier
auout au bout d'un moment ils
découvrirent le long de la rivière un
très grand cocotier PHENO se Issa sur
les épaules de Chiki et ensemble ils
grimpèrent jusqu'au sommet ils étaient
sur le point de cueillir la plus grosse
noix de coco quand ils entendirent un
bruissement venant des
fourês bas les pattes cria un grand
singe très fâché qui bondit tout à coup
hors du Buisson qu'est-ce qui vous passe
par la tête c'est mon
cocotier vociféra-t-il en agitant ses
bras de manière menaçante ils glissèrent
rapidement le long du Tron et se mirent
à courir le plus vite possible pour que
le grand singe en colère ne les rattrape
pas nous avons eu de la chance de nous
échapper souous flash Chiki à le
temps pourtant fen était malheureux il
est tard à présent sanglotta-t-il et je
n'ai toujours pas de cadeau pour maman
attends lança Chiki j'ai une idée que
tirais-tu d'aller lui chois chisir une
papaille bien juteuse mais oui ça lui
fera certainement très plaisir dit-il en
se retrouvant de bonne humeur les
papailles les plus savoureuses
poussaient près de la chute d'eau c'est
donc dans cette direction que les deux
amis se dirigèrent une fois encore Chiki
aida fenno à grimper jusqu'au sommet de
l'arbre et ensemble ils cueillirent pour
la maman de Pho la papaille la plus mû
et la plus grosse qu'il purent
trouver quand ils arrivèrent à la maison
il était déjà tard et la maman de PHENO
les attendait
ou voilà enfin je m'inquiétais leur
dit-elle PHENO était tellement content
de revoir sa maman qu'il courut vers
elle laissant glisser la papaille qu'il
tenait jusque- là serré sous son aile
attention cria Chiki la maman de Phen
bondit et rattrapa la papaille juste
avant qu'elle ne s'écrase au sol
ouf juste attend s'exclama PHENO avec
soulagement joyeux anniversaire maman
j'espère que ton cadeau te plaît mon
chéri c'est le plus beau cadeau que j'ai
jamais eu répondit sa
[Musique]
maman